be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
as you guys can see I have a visitor
behind me I have a visitor here okay we
get to keep her right it's been 14 days
since you showed up on our back door and
and we get to keep her now those guys
who don't know um like Mariah was
streaming on Twitch right on on e codes
where she does her cooking and she cooks
out of a video game-themed cookbooks she
was finishing up her stream and like a
cat just showed up on the back doorstep
and we were just like what and it was
kind of crazy
because it was like okay well this is
this is pretty awesome so we took it to
the Humane Society and it wasn't
microchipped and they were like well you
have 14 days for the original owners to
claim it and if the original owners
don't claim it then it's yours you can
you can have it and 14 days passed two
days ago I see actually probably off
four days ago so like it's been about 18
days so she's officially ours now and
she is a Hellion she's adorable but she
is a Hellion at the same time which by
the way I took my pre-workout and it's
starting to kick in
so I'm probably gonna be running like a
million miles a minute in this video uh
just FYI
just so you guys know vanos created
mutants but not intentionally okay so
how does how does this work right I have
this theory of work Thanos basically
creating mutants how does all this come
to a head okay so in Marvel Comics this
is this this gonna seem like a crazy
theory right this is gonna see
absolutely absolutely bonkers there is a
kind of theory running around this
similar to this except it's really based
more on the reality stone and and
essentially saying that like with Thanos
doing what he did it just you know
reality was manipulated in such a way to
where either he willed mutants into
existence or they came into existence on
their own people just sort of developing
extremes different things like that like
you just kind of modified their genes
and sort of went forward from there um
this was a little bit different but the
idea behind this is that all this ties
in to the events of operation galactic
storm so so so what is this what's
what's Operation galactic storm what's
the basis behind this story well as we
know in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
they love taking the idea of existing
stories or names and then changing them
into something else but keeping the name
the same right for example the Russo
brothers had made a statement at one
point saying that there was no story I'm
Alma College called endgame right that's
not true there's actually an x-factor
story called end game where x-factor and
the Inhumans I think face off against
the villain of apocalypse or the villain
apocalypse in order to save the life of
Nathan summers who goes on to become the
character of cable right so like we know
that story exists and so just kind of
applying that to an Avengers
story and then going forward and calling
it a day is what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe likes to do and so doing the
same concept with galactic storm really
makes sense
so galactic storm was a story that was
written in Marvel Comics back in the day
that's centered on a war between the the
Kree race and the Shiar Empire now you
guys have heard of the creek well you've
seen Captain Marvel you guys know what
the Kree is it's just a race out there
that exists in the universe and it has
this great big huge expanding empire the
difference between the Shiar Empire and
the Kree Empire or even the scroll
Empire is that the Shiar is not a
singular race right it's a whole bunch
of different races all of whom swear
allegiance to whoever's running the
Empire at the time when the Shiar first
popped up in Marvel I want to say it was
dick in and then after the can it was
his sister Lalande rrah and then after
lilandra it turned into maybe war bird I
think like like a lot of your sister war
bird whatever it was um and then I think
more recently it's been gladiator it's
been quelle arc right you know not
Kellogg not the cereal company but it
was it was Kell Ark who's a strontium
basically like Marvel's version of
Superman except that his powers are tied
into his confidence so the less
confident he is a less powerful he
becomes and so because of that the Shiar
really kind of stands alone in terms of
the nature of its of his empire and how
it functions but the idea behind this
was that at some point in the early days
or not really even in early Daiso time
in the past of the Kree empires
existence the supreme intelligence which
is kind of their religious leader slash
you know combination of all the smartest
minds that have ever existed in the Kree
race had basically tasked one of their
member to travel to a place called the
Citadel of light and shadow
now the Citadel of light and shadow is
home to a place called the crystal of
the ultimate vision sometimes what's
called the crystal of the final vision
but whatever it is those individuals who
were able to use the power of the
crystal basically get like cosmic
awareness on a vast amount of power
right like omnipotence essentially the
idea behind this is you can't just walk
in and take it right it's not a baseball
sitting on the ground yeah I'll let you
go and you pick up the crystal and then
horns blare and confetti falls and
congratulations you've achieved
omnipotence have fun it doesn't really
work that way right listen how the
crystal works instead what it does is it
is it like gives you a whole bunch of
different like tests things like that
just getting into the Citadel
they never itself is hard enough let
alone making your way through the
Citadel and then finally getting to the
crystal but the final test of the
crystal is what always in snares people
is what always catches people and the
reason why is because those individuals
who
about the crystal of ultimate vision are
really kind of entranced and they're
drawn to it because of the power they
could possess and they could basically
use it and say I can do anything I want
to I can become God and their
motivations are usually selfish in
nature a sir
either the motivations are based on like
making their race all-powerful or making
themselves all-powerful and so what
happens is when a person approaches the
crystal and tries to grab it the crystal
will basically analyze their deepest
desires and if the desires are
inherently selfish in nature which is to
say they want to use the crystal for
their own personal goals then the
crystal will freeze the entire
evolutionary process of their race right
like their race will never progress
further along the evolutionary line
it'll stay exactly where it is they can
still procreate and they can still have
kids different things like that but
they'll never reach the the next state
meaning that their lifespan is basically
cut short then eventually their entire
race will die out before it should those
individuals who don't want to use the
crystal for nefarious purposes you don't
want to use it for selfish purposes you
want to like help the universe or
something along those lines ultimately
they'd end up putting it back anyway
because it's just such an extreme amount
of power right we saw that in the
uncanny x-men story with Wolverine when
he got the crystal he achieved like
cosmic awareness he was omnipotent for a
short amount of time and he's like this
is just too much power for one person to
possess I don't want this and he
ultimately put it back alter the old one
when that happens a crystal will kind of
reward you of sorts with like you know
cosmic awareness a short amount of
omnipotence and then of course it'll go
back to you know being it's being in its
normal form what ended up happening is
this member of the Kree race took the
crystal or at least tried to attain the
crystal with selfish intentions right
basically moving the Kree race to a
point where it could be come down it can
really kind of I guess implement its
dominion over the entirety of the
universe and the result was that the
crystal of ultimate vision froze the
evolutionary race of the creek that's
why they hadn't really a progressive
really changed at all all that came to a
head during Operation galactic storm and
during this story the the Kree initiated
a war with the Shiar knowing that the
Shiar would eventually detonate a mega
bomb right the Nega bomb is basically a
bomb based off the Negev and which
essentially are like a like a portal or
kind of like a vector of sorts for
antimatter energy the long and short of
it is that like if you detonate them
like if you rip them open
it's an insane amount of power that
would come out right and that was the
nature behind the Nega bomb that when it
was detonated it was enough to wipe out
in a sty and an entire star system and
it did right like I mean it literally
destroyed Billy
of the Kree Empire and and it actually I
think it wiped out like 99% of the race
or something along those lines but the
supreme intelligence was gambling on
that and the reason why is because when
that happened the natural response the
the response of nature itself was to
push the Kree into its next evolutionary
state right it was basically say okay
we're gonna progress along the
evolutionary chain and the result is
that the Kree have been have been
basically evolving ever since what I'm
saying is take that concept and apply to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that when
Thanos popped up and Thanos wiped out
half the life in the universe that of
course half the life on earth was gone
and the natural response of losing you
know half its population was nature
itself reacted basically just said like
genes are gonna start manifesting now
and and it's not even that genes
appeared for the first time they had
always been there and they just started
activating because of that right because
say for example that what Marvel does is
is with the Eternals movie they
basically give us the in comic book
origin of mutants through the Eternals
film right because those you guys don't
know and we've tried by this a bunch of
times before so bear with me if you've
heard this but those are guys who don't
know basically when it comes to the
Eternals they're one of three groups
right there it's really kind of like a
trifecta group and the reason why is
because in the early days you had what
we're called The Wanderers and The
Wanderers were basically like the
missing link between primate and modern
man and so what ended up happening is a
Celestials visited earth in the very
early days oh really I have in the early
days like thirty thousand years ago so
they were kind of you know it was it was
relatively recently in comparison to
like the entire history of the world but
uh but they visited earth about thirty
thousand years ago and what they did is
they took this group called the
Wanderers and they split them into
thirds one-third basically how their
genes modified to where they associate
became angelic in nature right like they
were like angels right they could fly
that gets happened to cosmic energies
all kinds of cool stuff and they were
called the Eternals the second group
have their gene is destabilized meaning
we didn't really know what the
aftereffect or what the weather
ramifications of that was going to be
what ended up happening is they became
really grotesque in nature right they
were basically like like monsters or
troll looking things and they for the
most part resided underground but they
also have a half-life meaning that every
generation that came after lived shorter
than the generation before it had like a
shorter lifespan than the generation
before and in the third group had their
genes modified so that somewhere along
the line those genes would manifest and
then they were started developing powers
right so it was basically an X gene
which gave virtu to mutants now those
those genetic modification
were also used to explain why it is a
Bruce Banner became the Incredible Hulk
instead of like a giant mass of tumors
you know why it is that Steve Rogers was
able to essentially be blasted with like
radiation and given a given you know the
Super Soldier Serum and become Captain
America instead of like dying some
horrendous death you know or something
along those lines and so it was
basically that these genes were modified
in a way to where they would lend
themselves to developing powers or
develop powers outright through an X
gene and so what I'm saying is that if
they decide to go with that in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then what it
means is that since the Celestials had
arrived on earth and since the creation
of the Eternals the creation of the
deviants and the modification of
baseline humans these genes have been
waiting to be activated is really all it
is now you could go the Ultimate
Universe route where it basically turns
out that humans activate those genes and
the activation process is synthesized
and it's spread throughout the world
then mutants pop up or they could go
with this one in addition to a litany of
others they can go with this one and
basically say that when Thanos wiped out
half the life in the universe half the
life on Earth was gone and nature's
reaction was to basically hit the panic
button and say like okay push and and
basically started activating all these
genes and in turn like all these mutants
started popping up all over the place
the question you have to ask here this
is where things don't really make a
whole lot of sense the question you have
to ask here is is between the events of
the end of infinity war in the start of
Avengers in game we got five years and
so while we didn't really see a whole
lot of what happened during that five
year window who was focused largely on
the Avengers the question is like
wouldn't we have seen some kind of
reference to the fact that like mutants
or among us or people with extraordinary
abilities are popping up or something
along those lines
they could not do that and just say like
that was all just focus on the Avengers
now let's focus on that five-year gap
that basically introduced x-men and
mutants and so on right I mean that's
literally what you could do you could do
like an x-men film and you can basically
say x-men one takes place in that five
year window when half the life in the
universe was wiped out right and like
now that everybody's basically returned
you know half the population returns
only to find out that like there's all
these mutants around here now like
nobody knows how to cope with them or
anything along those lines they're
blamed for the fact that half the life
in the universe is wiped out because you
know I mean a lot of people knew about
Thanos but they didn't really know the
ins and outs of it in terms of like the
Infinity stones and all that kind of
stuff I mean they kind of did you know
as time went on but you know they just
refer to it as the blip you know even in
spider-man far from home the indications
seem to be that people didn't really
know what it was that led to half-life
they you know
life on earth being wiped out they just
know it got wiped out and then it came
back right so if that's the case and and
most of humanity doesn't know what
happened and then if meat was pop up
well there was a reason for a while
humanity hates mutants because they
believe that mutants were the ones who
did it right half the unit half the life
on the planet basically vanishes and
then suddenly these people with
superpowers start popping up there's an
easy scapegoat so I don't know I mean
there's a bunch of different options you
can go with in terms of making this work
in terms of putting this concept to use
but I don't know let me know what you
guys think I'm kind of curious you let
me know what you guys think about this
idea if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys the
sub button to become part of the rod
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
my pre-workouts kickin in peace
[Music]